[Applause]
okay
you ready okay welcome back we're here
with the host of the talk and we're
playing taboo
now team Cheryl is in the lead six to
five but let's see a team drooping catch
up right now we're gonna start with
Jerry coming up here you're giving the
clue
we're putting one minute on the clock
remember there's a word you're trying to
get your team to guess you can't say the
other word or I'll buzz you let's go
Jerry okay here we go uh when you finish
eating you put these in a dishwasher yes
that's right
um this is uh if it's a fancy party you
put it out on a piece of wood and
there's some fruits
cheese board and it's a specific typo
Swiss cheese
thank you
okay in your um uh when you're on a
computer you check your uh emails okay
but it goes in the garbage trash it goes
in the garbage delete
garbage
you were looking for spam spam yes
I apologize
Jerry that wasn't bad you you got three
your team has a total of nine so Drew's
team you gotta get four to tie which
means it drew you're up
[Applause]
this is so hard you know because it's
like all the things you can't say yeah
exactly the point of taboo right okay
now you got to get four to tight if you
get five you take the win you got it
uh-huh all right you ready team 60
seconds on the clock Drew take it away
all right you're swinging from the sky
with your handset does it just swing in
front of the cam on the from the tree
they're um they're jeweled uh they are
on the top uh they Diamond provide
um illumination
and you're swinging from the bars
um
okay if you don't put one on my finger
you're a single lady yes and what is
this
okay uh uh oh God I'm
so therefore for this um your mascara is
running a mascara yes 15 seconds we need
one more famous Beatles song Yellow
[Applause]
so close Drew you got nine they have
nine which means you're all going home
with open ear wireless headphones from
conduction Labs hey
well good I love what everybody's a
winner we'll be right back with more
with the song
[Music]